what about Trump what's going on there
what's going on there exactly you know
with interesting listening to Trump's
inauguration speech because I detected
elements of national socialist thought
in it you know and I not being
dismissive I'm seriously not being
dismissive but when you radically
activate on the side of the left you
call forth compensatory forces and
they're not in your control and like
Trump opened his speech you just read it
it's he sounds like a 1950 socialist you
know he's going to use the power of the
state to bring the industry home to
produce a lot of infrastructure it's a
state business unity with the state in
charge and then at the end of his speech
which is where he stops being a at least
the International kind of socialist he
says well borders are really important
and so is national identity and you know
he does embed that it within belief in
God which is probably a good thing
assuming that he's serious about that
but you know the fact that Trump was
elected in the end that there was such a
fight between him and the clintonites
and that the Clinton Knights were
playing identity politics instead of
speaking for the working-class who then
Trump co-opted like he should have there
there's a war going on there and then
well what about brexit what's going on
there and what about france with marine
lepen and what about poland with
wielders you know watch it we're in a
chaotic time and you know I've got
letters from people all over the world
who tell me how they can't say what they
think it's like oh well that's not very
good
and they're kind of happy with me
because maybe they think that I
emboldened them in some way and so good
good for that hypothetically and most of
the people who wrote me the overwhelming
majority were reasonable so pretty happy
about that too but and maybe I'm wrong
about my damn diagnosis because like
what do I know but I do have this
proclivity to get to the bottom of
things and what's at the bottom of this
is an ideological war or philosophical
war it's even deeper than that it might
even be deeper than a philosophical war
which is something that's more like a
metaphysical or theological war you know
it depends on how far down you look and
the post modernists know exactly what
they're doing this is accidental of
course you shut down speakers you don't
agree with
you can't have a dialogue with and then
anyways because human beings can't have
dialogue there's no such thing as a
human individual there's no such thing
as truth here's the postmodern world
it's the Hobbesian nightmare it's
everyone against everyone else except
it's not individuals it's group and
you're stuck in your damn group and it's
the only thing about you anyways it's
relevant which is why we might base our
hiring on it for example and you're
oppressed and even if you don't know it
it's only because you've internalized it
and it's the only thing that's real
about you anyways and I can't talk to
you because I'm in my own little silo of
privileged belief and besides we can't
use logic because that doesn't exist and
so you're in a group and I'm in a group
and all we can do is have a war or we
can talk but we don't get to talk
because you can't talk if you're a
postmodernist because speech is just
chatter so it's just chatter that it
supports the people in power that's how
they think and so the whole world is
this little armed war of identity group
against identity group against identity
group and you shut down people who don't
agree with you because why should you
let them talk it's you don't believe in
any of the reasons why you would let
someone talk so this isn't accidental
it's not because they're afraid although
it's also because of that they hijack
you know fear they hijack compassion
they make anyone who who puts forward an
alternative view into a terrorist of
ideas and someone who's heartless at the
core which is really incredibly
intelligent it's such a good strategy
it's so devious and brilliant and it's
so effective because who wants a who the
hell wants to be labeled a bigot you
probably are a damn biggest just like
everyone else so you know what it's easy
to make people feel guilty about that
maybe they should